[Musique]
bonjour mesdames messieurs ici céline
galipeau bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale du jour du souvenir en hommage
aux soldats canadiens disparus un
hommage qui prend cette année une
signifiait une signification toute
particulière puisqu'on célèbre
aujourd'hui le 100e anniversaire de la
signature de l'armistice qui a marqué la
fin des combats de la première guerre
mondiale
la victoire des alliés et la défaite de
l'allemagne
alors ces images ou parier en direct de
la place de la confédération à ottawa où
s'élèvent au centre le monument
commémoratif de guerre c'est une belle
journée mais assez froide il fait moins
quatre degrés celsius et comme toujours
ce sera une cérémonie tourné vers le
passé en hommage aux 116 1000 canadiens
qui ont donné leur vie au cours de
différentes guerres c'est une occasion
bien sûr de se recueillir de penser à
ceux et à celles qui ont servi et à tous
ceux qui servent encore notre pays
alors vous voyez des images des images
des gens qui sont venus assister à cette
cérémonie à ottawa il ya aussi beaucoup
d'anciens combattants qui sont déjà
installés
alors avec moi sur l'autre plateau je
vous présente tout de suite mais deux
invités andré champagne historiens grand
collaborateur de notre radio que l'on
connaît depuis bien longtemps et le
brigadier l'ancien brigadier général
gaston côté
bonjour à vous deux merci d'être ici
avec nous ce côté je vois que vous avez
amenez vos médailles avec vous voyez
fatima est ce que vous avez servi
pendant une trentaine d'années vous êtes
un combat aussi et puis c'était toute
démission mémorable quoi que les
problèmes sont encore présents dans ces
pays là malheureusement la mission ne
suivent pas toujours pas réglé tous les
problèmes ça prend également une
solution politique dans toutes ces
choses là comme la première guerre
mondiale alors à 11h ce 11e jour du 11e
mois il y aura deux minutes de silence
bien sûr pour marquer c'est l'entrée en
vigueur de l'armistice qui a mis fin
donc à cette première guerre mondiale
celle qu'on espérait être la der de der
la dernière mais les chiffres dépassent
un peu l'entendement quand on regarde
toujours avec nos yeux d'aujourd'hui
quand même 70 millions de soldats
mobilisés 10 millions morts parmi les
combattants donc plus de 60 civils
canadiens auxquels il faut ajouter des
millions de morts parmi les civils alors
on parle du devoir de mémoire pourquoi
c'est important de se rappeler parce que
ça fait partie ni ça fait partie de
l'histoire du canada ça fait partie de
l'histoire européenne se répartit
d'histoire mondial et il ya une question
de respect envers les militaires et des
hommes en général ici qui présente ce
côté on doit on doit on doit faire en
sorte que les générations actuelles et
jeunes gens qui vont ensuite sache ce
qui s'est passé et en tant que citoyens
peu importe le pays
si notre veillée participent à des
guerres on doit rappeler aux citoyens
parce que cette répartie dans cl ce pays
parce qu'il fait partie du devoir de
soins qui a un devoir de respect envers
ces gens qui servent le pays souvent au
sacrifice de leur vie dollars oui c'est
important comme le suis d'autant plus
important qu'on n'a jamais réellement
connu conflit sur le sol canadien alors
pour nous c'est important de revisiter
sa et de remercier les militaires qui
eux ont dû se déplacer dans des
territoires souvent très éloignés ce
soit pour une mission paix ou pour la
première ou la deuxième guerre mondiale
alors c'est important certainement pour
la population de respecter ce devoir là
et de aussi à ce moment là pour plonger
dans l'histoire de façon pas répéter
l'histoire du tout ce qui est quand même
le temps passe ça fait sans tendance et
quatre générations sa sentence à quatre
générations et puis cette importance
elle
et effectivement si ceux qui ont
participé on sait qu'ils sont tous morts
maintenant alors on va aller tout de
suite rejoindre mon collègue danielle
thibeault qui est sur place
tahoua daniel donc pas chaud là ça
n'affecte pas trop les anciens
combattants qui sont présents non mais
écoutez pas jusqu'ici mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas très chaud - 4° -9 avec le
facteur 20 ça semble pas incommoder les
anciens combattants et ça semble pas non
plus avoir eu d'impact sur la foule
parce que je voudrais que toutes les
cérémonies que j'ai couvert c'est l'une
des plus impressionnantes
ça aide qui ont choisi dimanche matin
les gens ont peut-être un peu plus
flexibilité dans les horaires mais est
arrivé déjà beaucoup de gens depuis tôt
ce matin plusieurs milliers de personnes
massées tout le tour du de la place de
la confédération c'est une image qui
particulièrement impressionnant et on
attend beaucoup de dignité à cette
cérémonie même s'il ya quelques absents
on sait oui bon alors justin trudeau ne
sera pas ici il est en déplacement
présentement dans la région de paris il
a participé aux cérémonies organisées là
bas ce matin un peu plus tôt par contre
chauny push sera ici elle accompagnera
celui qui représentera le gouvernement
canadien pour l'occasion c'est le
ministre de la défense argue jitsu john
holmes se fit grégoire trudeau sera avec
lui
de même qu'une série de dignitaires
évidemment et puis il ya la gouverneure
générale julie payette qui sera celle
qui présidera les cérémonies 6 me ouais
julie payette qui était en belgique hier
elle a dû faire le voyage sorte de
retour assez rapidement pour être ici
présentes à cette cérémonie
oui alors j'ai pas vu ce les détails de
son plan de vol mais elle a dû passer
une bonne partie des dernières heures
dans un avion entre la belgique et le
canada parce que vous le disiez elle a
participé aux cérémonies
il ya de cela une vingtaine d'heures
maintenant madame payette était là-bas
pour souligner la mémoire de georges
roze passe vous voyez les images
monsieur presse le dernier canadien
le dernier soldat canadien à être tombé
mort au champ d'honneur
là bas parce qu'un abattu par un tireur
d'élite
alma à 10h58 deux minutes à peine avant
le début de l'armistice la cérémonie a
eu lieu ce matin pour pour pour
souligner amont pour souligner la
mémoire de monsieur à ma surprise ce
sont c'est un neveu du de l'homme qui
qui étaient sur place
87 ans le neveu de monsieur pas ce qui
est allé déposer une gerbe de fleurs on
en a aussi profité pour inaugurer un
monument qui a la mémoire de monsieur
monsieur place c'est une une énorme
gooch qui a qui trône sur le site
maintenant là le sculpteur voilà vous la
voyez vous voyez l'image
le sculpteur a voulu que sa puce est
interprété de deux façons c'est une lame
ou c'est une goutte de sang cela sera
dans l'oeil du visiteur dans madame
payet étaient sur place ce matin plutôt
une vingtaine d'heures maintenant pour
inaugurer ce monument à la mémoire des
soldats police alors merci beaucoup
daniel on vous retrouvera un peu plus
tard et vous savez le grand enjeu de
cette guerre on peut dire que c'était
aussi paris conquérir la ville lumière
aurait été un symbole très fort pour les
allemands et sa défense l'était tout
autant pour les français alors il était
peut-être approprié que ce soit là sur
les champs elysées qu'a eu lieu la plus
importante cérémonie réunissant les
gagnants et les perdants de ce conflit
un siècle plus tard je rejoins un
philippe vincent foisy qui suit le
premier ministre alors philippe vincent
une cérémonie quand même sous haute
sécurité au pied de l'arc de triomphe
parce qu'elle s'est déroulée en présence
d'une dizaine de chefs d'état dont le
premier ministre justin trudeau rester
dîner je voudrais que c'était une
cérémonie qui était sobre et solennelle
à la fois presque tous les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement sont arrivés ensemble
sous l'arc de triomphe
le président français la chancelière
allemande angela merkel étaient assis
côte à côte pendant la cérémonie
le violoncelliste yo yo ma à jouer la
cinquième suite de bach y a aussi des
lycéens qui ont lu des lettres qui avait
été écrite en 1918 le 11 novembre par
des soldats qui étaient au front et qui
disait à quel point ils étaient soit
incrédule soit très joyeux que
finalement la guerre
soit terminé emmanuel macron ensuite
prononcé un discours où il a demandé aux
français et à tout le reste du monde de
se souvenir des sacrifices qui ont été
faits pendant cette guerre est aussi de
faire attention pour éviter que les
démons du passé ne ressurgisse que ce
jour anniversaire soit donc celui où se
renouvellent l'éternel fidélité à nos
morts ce sont une fois de plus ce
serment des nations de placer la paix
plus haut que tout 40 ans connaissant le
prix nous en savons le poids nous en
savons les exigences hier justin trudeau
a souligné aussi le jour du souvenir à
vimy lors d'une cérémonie à saveur
canadienne vimy c'est l'une des
victoires militaires les plus
importantes pour le canada lors de la
première guerre mondiale mais elle s'est
fait au coût de ces grands sacrifices il
ya plus de dix mille canadiens qui ont
été soit tués ou blessés ils étaient
devant le monument qui était très
imposant ensuite il a prononcé un
discours dans le cimetière où sont
enterrés une centaine de canadiens
on se sent teneur de l'armistice de la
première guerre mondiale
on a une pensée spéciale pour ceux qui
se sont battus avec courage pour les
valeurs qui nous sont chères à ces
soldats passés et présents qui ont fait
le sacrifice de leur vie pour leur pays
est finie vincent monsieur trudeau var
est à paris donc parce qu'il y a un
grand forum sur la paix qui a été
organisée par emmanuel macron qui se
veut ce forum un peu un plaidoyer contre
le déclin de l'ordre mondial
multilatérale parce qu'on est dans une
période assez propice ont aussi au
populisme au repli sur soi donc un forum
être très significatif pour le président
français oui un forum ou emmanuel macron
invités et tous les dirigeants qui ont
participé à la première guerre mondiale
un forum où il va y avoir des
discussions pour parler du
multilatéralisme et aussi de parler des
meilleures façons de contrer les menaces
auxquelles le monde en ce moment faire
face emmanuel macron en a parlé lors de
l'ouverture de ce dans son discours
d'ouverture
il a parlé des changements climatiques
il a parlé des inégalités des menaces ou
sico sont leurs hôtes sur soi
l'antisémitisme pour la paix et la
sécurité dans le monde c'est un forum
qui se veut annuel c'est la première la
première la première en fait la première
fois qu'il fait ce forum ici à paris il
compterait invité les dirigeants
chaque année afin d'avoir ses parents où
on peut discuter
on peut parler des enjeux importants il
a fait l'apologie ce matin de l'onu il a
fait l'apologie de vision européenne les
plus tard dans la journée justin trudeau
va rencontrer emmanuel macron ensemble
avec d'autres dirigeants ils vont signer
un pacte pour l'information à
l'invitation de reporters sans
frontières
voilà un monsieur soulignons que
monsieur donald trump lui ne participe
pas à ce sommet disons que il n'est pas
très porté sur le multilatéralisme à la
remercie beaucoup philippe vincent et
plus tôt aujourd'hui à londres la reine
elizabeth ii entouré de la duchesse de
cornouailles camilla parker bowles et de
la duchesse de cambridge catherine
middleton a regardé son fils le prince
charles déposé en son nom c'est la
deuxième année que ça se produit une
couronne sur le cénotaphe de londres et
pour l'occasion ce dernier était
accompagné du président allemand frank
walter steinmeier
un geste donc très symbolique qui montre
la réconciliation entre les deux nations
en ce 100e anniversaire de l'armistice
alors pendant qu'on attend ici à ottawa
l'arrivée de la représentante de la
reine justement la gouvernance générale
julie payette qui devrait arriver dans
les prochaines minutes donc parlons un
peu de ces cérémonies quand même très
symbolique un lavoir
le président allemand d'un côté et aussi
cette réconciliation très très publique
est depuis plusieurs années entre la
france et l'allemagne du sein phénomène
qui avait commencé sous de gaulle avec
le
le chancelier adenauer ça s'est
poursuivi m françois mitterrand puis
chancelier kohl et maintenant madame
merkel et monsieur monsieur ma croûte
dans un contexte comme on avait souligné
tantôt où il ya une remise en question
de l'ordre mondial
le président américain remet en question
le temps la chine a des ambitions la
poule à la russie n'a ri c'est une des
ambitions donc cent ans après la fin de
la paix ce qu'on réalise c'est que c'est
que l'homme issu de la première guerre
mondiale et s'effritent s'effrite
complètement et qu'on n'est jamais
parvenu on n'est jamais parvenu à sortir
de ce conflit l'heure parce que de ce
conflit là on est jeune je repérais part
d'une guerre de 30 ans qui commence à 14
ans d'histoire inah 40 45
mais pendant 14 18 nasty y est vous avez
l'année 1917 le communisme triomphant
russie les états-unis émergent les deux
pays qui vont dominer le 20e six sont
toujours là la russie la russie et le
début de la fin on croyait que tout est
terminé à 81 ans et la compétition la
rivalité est à nouveau très présent et
c'est vraiment une guerre qui aura
façonné le monde qui aura changé vie de
liz empire s'effondre l' empire
austro-hongrois la dent perotto style
empire ottoman il ya d'une nouvelle
nation qui émerge aussi s'ils sont là
aujourd'hui
aussi c'est en 1914 l'europe est le
continent qui domine la planète en 1918
ce n'est plus cas donc il ya un
vieillard d'europe est un vieil ordre
mondial qui s'est complètement effondrée
puis laisser place à aux désordres
actuels et tantôt en avant l'émission
quasi côté par l'est de la les accords
famille du moyen-orient les accords
sykes picot vous le savez insu oui bien
ça aussi il ya des conflits qui sont nés
la wii continue encore janvier mais il y
avait aussi quand même un changement
drôle c'est qu'à la fin de la première
guerre mondiale oui les américains
avaient plus de prévalence maintenant
avait une voix internationales plus
fortes et ce qui avait donné naissance
finalement société des nations mais la
société d'un des nations peut-être été
un peu perverti un sens qu' elle n'a
jamais réussi à avoir l'acceptation
global d'une part elle n'a jamais réussi
à avoir les moyens nécessaires aussi
pour imposer la paix par des voies
diplomatiques
les américains sont intervenus aussi
dans les accords sykes picot qui était
réellement ce moment là le partage de
l'empiré ottoman et ce n'était pas par
regardeur d'armes c'est parce que
réellement il y avait des des gains à
faire des gains financiers à faire et
surtout aussi le pétrole qui étaient
déjà dans la ligne de mire de certains
groupes d'intérêts américains pour le
canada en fait ça a changé beaucoup de
choses
on parle d'un mythe fondateur du mythe
fondateur du canada s'est faite tout le
monde et peut-être pas d'accord avec ça
mais quand même c'est le moment où le
canada surtout au canada anglais
retrouver son identité
en 1914 et canadiens anglais se
définissent comme des membres de l'
empire britannique
d'ailleurs la moitié des soldats qui
vont s'enrôler dans la nuit dans l'armée
canadienne était était né en
grande-bretagne venaient de
grande-bretagne et s'identifier à la
grande-bretagne à l'empiré britannique
mais en participant à la guerre entre
1914 et 1918 ce qui s'est déclenchée au
canada anglais c'est évident est que
nous sommes nous formons une nation et
que cette nation à la s'appelle le
canada et que désormais nous devons
avoir voix au chapitre d'avoir une
représentation sur la scène intérieure
il nous devons cesser de laisser
l'angleterre contrôler notre politique
étrangère
donc il ya vraiment dans l'histoire du
canada c'est vraiment un moment c'est
vraiment un moment clis des moments
civile il ya un avant 14 puis un après
et puis c'est vraiment le moment où le
canada surtout week-end en anglais
soient définis alors il aura l'occasion
d'en reparler on voit ici le ministre de
la défense monsieur cette jeanne dont
qui représente le premier ministre
trudeau et madame sophie grégoire qui
sont là on attend bien sûr dans quelques
instants l'arrivée de la gouverneure
générale mais aussi celle de la mer
décorés de la croix d'argent
c'est une mère qui représentent toutes
celles qui ont perdu un fils ou une
fille au service du canada et il s'agit
cette année de madame anita cenerini de
vol de winnipeg son fils thomas swayze
est mort en 2004 il s'est enlevé la vie
à son retour d'afghanistan
et ça c'est une première parce que
jamais auparavant la mère d'un soldat
qui a mis fin à ses jours n'avait encore
été honorés ainsi notre journaliste rémi
gauthier a rencontré cette mère qui veut
quand même porter un message d'espoir en
mémoire de son fils des ans seule dans
sa maison de winnipeg
anita cenerini montre des photos de
celui dont il est si fier
le soldat towers jlt son aîné qui s'est
enlevé la vie le 8 mai 2004 à l'âge de
22 ans
safran est le premier soldat avoir mis
fin à ses jours au retour d'afghanistan
même si la tragédie a eu lieu sur la
base de petawawa en ontario moins de
trois mois après son retour elle n'est
pas considérée comme ayant eu lieu en
service sa mère est convaincu que
l'émission a changé le jeune homme
aimant et d'où qu'elle a élevées
treize ans plus tard son intuition est
confirmée et l'armée change sa position
le gist de thomis est liée à son
déploiement en afghanistan
il reçoit donc le médaille du sacrifice
et sa mère la croix du souvenir remise
aux proches de ceux morts en service
think you l'armée change anita cenerini
a été choisie mère nationales de la
croix d'argent déterminé par la légion
royale canadienne
elle représentera toutes celles qui ont
perdu un enfant au service de la patrie
lors de la cérémonie de souvenir et pour
toute une année
c'est la chance pour elle de changer les
mentalités au sein de l'institution dont
elle est à la fois si fier ici déçu du
théâtre d'art pour énumérer card stud
asking for hope
pour ceux qui choisissent comme tamise
de servir leur patrie
anita cenerini crois que les choses
heureusement s'améliore et qu'ils ont
accès un meilleur soutien et nehru et
d'un père mort
et voilà justement madame ses narines et
qui la mer nationales de la croix
d'argent donc ira un peu plus tard
déposé une gerbe au nom de toutes les
mères qui ont perdu un fils ou une fille
et elle est accueillie en ce moment par
les dignitaires pour elle est
accompagnée vous le voyez juste derrière
elle la par son époux c'est quand même
un honneur qui qui montre gaston côté
qu'il ya une certaine ouverture de la
part de l'armée parce que c'était
quelque chose qui était très tabou de
parler de ces soldats qui sont
absolument et puis on a eu beaucoup de
difficulté à s'ajuster finalement cette
nouvelle réalité depuis surtout la
guerre d'afghanistan mais je crois que
ce qui est encore plus dangereux c'était
la guerre en yougoslavie qui était une
mission de paix et pour laquelle on ya
eu beaucoup de suicides par la suite
faisait que ce s'est fait aussi dans une
période où les phases armes est en
réduction importante on passait de 86400
à 60000 comme effectifs autorisés et on
allait en afghanistan pardon en
yougoslavie avait pétition alors durant
les années 90 il ya des soldats qui ont
été cinq fois en afghanistan
alors ça représente quand même presque
cinq ans sur dix ans où sont déployés
et puis tout ça par des mandats qui sont
est très équivoques avec des moyens des
règles d'engagement qui était totalement
inadéquate pour les espoirs qui étaient
placés dans cette mission là pour la
première fois on reconnaît en fait que
le que le stress -o déployant le stress
lié aux combats mène peut mener à la
mort jim à fait humain puis lens on voit
des images de la gouverneure générale
julie payette qui arrive donc pour cette
cérémonie du jour du souvenir en ce 100e
anniversaire de la fin de la première
guerre mondiale
dans madame julie payette est accompagné
de son fils on va le voir dans quelques
instants de son fils lauriers
alors les le commandant en chef des
forces canadiennes elle est donc en
uniforme comme le veut la tradition
cette année elle porte uniforme de la
marina c'est sa deuxième cérémonie en
tant que gouverneure générale dont je le
disais est à couper le son fils lauriers
elle va recevoir le salut vis royal dans
quelques instants avant d'être escortés
pour prendre place pour la cérémonie du
jour du souvenir
elle arrive donc de belgique où elle a
assisté aux cérémonies à mons en
belgique notamment où le dernier soldat
canadien s'est fait tuer on le disait on
en parlait tout à l'heure jack price
deux minutes il m'a avant la signature
de l'armistice il ya quelque chose de
vraiment de d'absurde parce que
l'armistice est signé à 5h20 mais pour
que l'armistice pourparlers pour la
suivre à l'excellent mois plus tard avec
moi pour que les portables si ça entre
en vigueur le 1 0 11e jour du 11e mois
[Musique]
seul
voilà alors maintenant tout le monde va
se mettre en place donc pour en position
pour la cérémonie qui est une cérémonie
toujours assez émouvant très cérémonial
bien sûr mais quitte un moment où on
peut se recueillir réfléchir un peu à
tous toutes ces guerres qui ont eu lieu
peut-être pas chez nous mais pour
lesquelles les canadiens ont combattu et
c'est sûr que on n'est pas touché
peut-être directement par ses
partenaires parce que parce que comme je
le disais ça c'est pas passé ici sur
notre territoire mais on réalise quand
on voit pendant qu'elle salue les autres
dignitaires
quand on voit ce qui les cérémonies par
exemple en belgique où elle était là
hier à quel point c'est important pour
ces pour les belges la cette libération
qu'ils ont qui dit il était tellement
heureux après quatre ans de deux guerres
la ville était occupé depuis 1914 est
libéré le dernier jour et puis pour
réussir hautement symbolique de la même
manière que pensons ou soutenir quand
les hollandais suite à deux gars vont
régulièrement l aérés et dans certains
endroits la hollande vous arrivez vous
dites que vous êtes canadien vous allez
est accueilli à bras ouverts encore il
ya même des rues qui portent le nom de
soldats canadiens d'abord alors c'est
quelque chose de presque inconnu ici au
canada et à mons on le disait il ya
veille à ce monument
cette cette sculpture convient convient
de d'inaugurer mais aussi un pot qui
s'appelle georges pas et ça les écoles
il ya beaucoup de choses qui érode qui
se souviennent en fait de ce soldat
parce que pour les belges c'est qu'ils
étaient ces gens qui avait traversé
l'atlantique pour venir les défendre en
fait pour les libérer il ya cette idylle
qui vont qu'on semble pas saisir ici
mais que l'iq que les citoyens belges de
la même note que les citoyens mais hier
dans l'est réalise parce que il ya eu
cette partie us et canadiens qui se sont
en roue libre pour aller combattre tout
à fait on va retrouver mon collègue
daniel à ottawa alors daniel on va
souligné
ici aussi on l'a vu des images de
l'horreur mais on va suis ici aussi de
manière particulière ce centième
anniversaire de l'armistice oui alors je
vais vous montrer d'abord cette petite
épinglettes qui a été remise à chacun
des vétérans qui à se présenter ce matin
ça a été conçu spécialement pour
souligner le 100e anniversaire de
l'armistice un truc qui étaient petites
épingles ait été fait de façon limitée
est donc remise aux vétérans ici ce
matin vous avez pour l'avoir remarqué
sur les images lors de l'arrivée des
différents dignitaires des gens qui sont
habillés avec des costumes militaires
d'époque ils sont six et il porte une
porte des vêtements une reproduction un
quasi parfaite de ce que les militaires
canadiens auraient porté dans les
tranchées durant la première guerre
mondiale ont ni même on a même été
jusqu'à réutiliser certains bouts de
louey on a même été jusqu'à réutiliser
certains boutons ou certains éléments de
cuivre qui faisait partie des costumes
originaux et qui ont été donc réintégré
dans la reproduction que ces zones la
porte aujourd'hui justement distribuer
distribués aux vétérans acquis arrivé ce
matin la petite épinglettes et ils vont
traverser la cérémonie est vraiment
seront là tout le long de la cérémonie
on a également il ya toujours une série
de gerbes de fleurs qui sont déposées
devant le monument commémoratif de
guerre du canada
ce matin vous allez voir il y en a il y
en a quelques-unes qui vont être un peu
différente qui sont des reproductions
des gerbes de fleurs qui ont été
utilisées lors du premier jour d'une
journée du souvenir en 1919 et gerbe
blanche comme on voit maintenant celle
ci un peu brunâtre on m'expliquait tout
à l'heure que c'est le cas parce qu'à
l'époque il faisait ses jambes et là
avec à peu près ce qu'ils avaient sous
la main donc souvent des broussailles
des trucs qui était peut-être un peu
bourré ou qui étaient pas très bonne
très bonne état
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on
avait on a on a ces gens peut-être un
petit peu plus un peu plus brune ap
vous allez voir ça arriver un peu plus
tard aujourd'hui alors voilà la
cérémonie sur le point de commencer on
regarde son ensemble et on va se
retrouver tout de suite après dans la
musique centrale des forces armées
canadiennes et au coeur des enfants
d'ottawa pour au canada
[Musique]
il
enfin
[Musique]
ah ah
ouais
[Musique]
ans
temps
[Musique]
ans
m
[Musique]
je
[Rires]
[Musique]
le championnat de la fraude et ils ne
vieilliront pas quand nous qui leur
avons serré qu il ait connaîtrons jamais
le courage ni le poids des années
quand viendra l'heure du crépuscule et
celle de l'aurore du souviendrons d'eux
je me rappelle pierre apakan muzeau ils
sont pas accaparer de la cancalaise
cauchy camp qui se lève on va s'appeler
des hommes on veut se rappeler des
hommes
[Musique]
williams nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
en ce lieu sacré où repose en paix le
soldat canadien inconnue pour nous
rappeler tous ceux et celles qui ont
fait l'ultime sacrifice dans ce jour du
centenaire de la signature de
l'armistice
nous voulons rendre hommage à ceux et
celles dont nous connaissons les noms et
à ceux et celles dont les noms sont
connus de dieu seul dans le respect des
croyances individuelles
j'avais toutes les personnes qui veulent
se joindre à moi dans la prière à
tourner leur coeur vers le dieu de leur
foi ou apprendre moment de réflexion
personnelle
please je vous invite à vous joindre à
moi dans la prière ou à prendre un
moment de réflexion personnelle lors
d'un god dieu d'amour nous te rendons
grâce pour ceux et celles qui ont donné
leur vie au service de la justice et de
la paix ce we know d'api nous savons que
la paix c'est plus que tolérée l'autre
se reconnaître dans les autres c'est
réaliser que nous sommes tous ensemble
sur le chemin de la vie lord rogers
c'est celle dieu de justice et de paix
c'est de nous a laissé tomber nos
propres armes d'exclusion d'intolérance
de haine et de conflits make a scene
showman fait de nous des instrument de
ta paix
afin d'apporter la réconciliation à
notre monde
or alors que nous nous rappelons ceux et
celles qui ont été marquées par des
blessures
v 0 visibles ou invisibles inspire nous
de prendre soin de tous nos militaires
qui ont été blessés dans leur corps leur
esprit et leur âme et reçoivent campagne
est de nous être plein de compassion à
l'égard de nos frères et soeurs que pour
des raisons connues ou inconnues ou
envisagés ou tenté de se suicider mais
we be camp nou sensible à la souffrance
des familles et des amis touchés par
cette tragédie
nous nous souvenons des familles
des amis des collègues et du personnel
soignant de ceux et celles qui en temps
de guerre et de paix ont fait le
sacrifice de leur vie pour restaurer la
paix soit leur soutien et leur force
dans les moments de deuil
nous prions pour tous les militaires
déployés autour du monde
dévoué au mieux être de l'humanité et à
la promotion de la justice et de la paix
inspire l'heure de donner le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes pour la cause de la liberté
nous prions pour notre souveraine sa
majesté élisabeth deux reines du canada
pour la gouverneure générale le premier
ministre le ministre de la défense
nationale le chef d'état major de la
défense et toutes les personnes en
autorité que la sagesse et la compassion
les accompagne dans leurs fonctions en
descente aux nyonnais ont fait annuler
du centenaire de l'armistice nous nous
souvenons et nous voulons un hommage à
nous disparu en répondant à leurs appels
à bâtir la paix espérances nous te
prions
venez vous asseoir
mesdames et messieurs le cortège du
royal dépôt sera maintenant les
couronnes
il y aura aussi une couronne spéciale
qui sera déposé à la mémoire des
canadiens et canadiennes qui ont servi
durant la première guerre mondiale
cent ans plus tard nous rendons hommage
à leur service et à leur sacrifice
remplissant notre devoir de ne jamais
oublier
[Musique]
m
les autres
[Musique]
oh
à
on voit les dignitaires donc c'était
monsieur saint john qu'on voyait le
ministre de la défense venir porter le
couronne au nom du gouvernement canadien
et qu'on entend une nouvelle version
musicale dont champ d'honneur ce fameux
poème de john mc rae qui est devenu un
peu très symbolique de cette journée du
souvenir donc une nouvelle version
musicale donc toutes ces images qu'on a
vu ces images et ces souvenirs de la
première guerre mondiale ça nous
replonge un peu dans un conflit dont on
a peut-être oublié à quel point il a été
brutale parce que quand on dit 70
millions de soldats 10 millions de
soldats morts des millions de civils qui
ont péri c'était vraiment quelque chose
d'inimaginable aujourd'hui pour
l'allemagne par exemple c'est un million
neuf cent mille morts pour la france et
un million quatre cent mille mois 1
millions de mutilés
six cent mille veuves de guerre on n'a
pas idée
on ne pollue bien à quel point il ya une
brutalisation et ce site européenne
issue de cette guerre là quand on
regarde la violence politique des années
20 des uns étant tous assez préparés
dans les tranchées de 14-18 dans les
combats de 14,8 il ya un phénomène qui
se produit de déshumanisation des
sociétés et puis ça conduit aux régimes
autoritaires sa conduite à la deuxième
guerre mondiale
et puis il ya ne s'est passé comme si
l'espèce de vernis civilisateur avait
complètement volé en éclats ce qui était
inacceptable
avant la guerre le devient pourquoi
parce que la ville la violence hélico
tidiane ly omniprésent parce que pour
les soldats qui parce qu'on parle d'une
guerre de tranchées à gazaupouy les
soldats canadiens par exemple aurait
tranché avec les roll et poule à boulbon
envahissante parce que
je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà existé
ces lieux là mais est assis de l'année
c'est très pluvieux le sol est très mou
et en plus de ceux élaborés par les obus
on n'a pas idée mon père l'a réellement
durant la première guerre mondiale d'un
milliard 500 millions d'obus qui ont été
tirées de différents calibres parce
qu'on pensait ce moment là qu'on était
capable également de gagner une guerre
uniquement grâce à l'artillerie ce qui
était faux parce que évidemment ça ça
donnait plus de problèmes qu'autre chose
parce que là pour pouvoir faire un
assaut saponay détonne gigantesque de
munitions et au bout du compte lorsqu'on
arrivait pour faire la cible l'ennemi
est encore auprès de cindy dit aussi que
nos soldats étaient très mal préparé
l'équipe effectivement parce que les
premières troupes qu'on envoyait y avait
de l'équipement qui est elle réellement
désuet les armes qu'on avait c'était le
fuji rose qui était une arme canadienne
qui était d'ailleurs fabriqué québec en
passant et qui avait là malheureusement
ne pouvait pas fonctionner avec la boue
elle sent veillesse pour malheur alors
les soldats avaient tendance à jeter
leurs armes canadienne pour demander une
à brittany qui étaient les lignes fines
l'équipement qu'on avait dans les
tranchées simplement donné où vous aviez
à ce moment là des décibels de bottes
qui font littéralement sur la soul la
présence de l'eau et de la boue j'avais
vu des personnes qui étaient habillés
avec des costumes historiques mais il y
avait une veste de cuir men veste de
cuir mouillé ça protège pas du foie
parce que l'automne il pleut tout le
temps
vous avez parlé de la brutalité la
moitié des soldats morts pendant la
grande guerre ont été déchiquetés par
des obus
l'idée du soldat inconnu est venue du
fait qu' on arrive on n'est pas parvenu
à identifier
près de la moitié dit ma douce d'où
cette volonté de salluit le soldat
inconnu qui ne reviendra jamais dont on
ne pourra jamais dire à la famille à
quel moment et lima dans quel état il
m'a donc et comme le disait être
commises et de général côté les
stratèges et ce n'était pas juste en
retard d'une guerre
les généraux toutes armes confondues en
1914 avec comme référence les guerres
napoléoniennes
alors qu'entre temps il y avait eu les
avancements dans l'artillerie
il y avait eu la mitrailleuse qui était
la reine des champs de bataille quitte
aider vous qui chantez littéralement des
soldats un exemple parmi d'autres le 22
août 1914 à la bataille de virton les
allemands ont massacré 27 mille soldats
français fait pas 27 mille morts et
blessés 27 mille morts en l'espace d'une
après midi et il était pratiquement
condamnés à mourir stationnement est on
est on est parvenu à vaincre le feu des
mitrailleuses
avec l'introduction de charme surtout le
chat un peu plus moderne à personne 1918
et puis c'était quand même l'expression
qui est devenu populaire par la suite la
chair à canon c'est réellement comme ça
que les gens se définissent l or ce
qu'ils allaient au front parce que il
était soumis finalement des barrages
d'artillerie intensifs qui laissait peu
de place réellement pour la survie et
qui causait aussi des problèmes
psychologiques vous vous rappellerez la
fameuse expression shellshock qui était
encore mal définies à l'époque c'était
réellement le stress post traumatique
étayer les gens pendant qu'on voit là
maintenant
d'autres personnes qui viennent déposer
des couronnes
on attend bien sûr le défilé des anciens
combattants qui va se mettre en place
pour eux c'est toujours un moment très
important c'est une forme de
reconnaissance aussi de pouvoir défiler
comme ça donc en attendant que tout ça
se met en place mais il faut quand même
souligner la résilience le travail des
soldats canadiens qui ont quand même
accompli beaucoup pendant secteur oui
parce qu'il ya quand même deux combats
qui sont très importants à remettre en
perspective la crête de vimy des
marabouts rien écouté les français les
anglais ont essayé de prendre la crête
de vimy ils ont payé 300 mille morts et
les canadiens finalement ont pris la
crête de vimy avec moins de 10000 morts
alors c'est sûr que ils ont ils ont
changé la façon dont on approchait les
tactiques
ils ont été très délibéré ils ont fait
aussi des pratiques de façon à ce que
tout le monde ait un rôle bien
particulier à jouer et ce qui était
réellement une redéfinition finalement
de comment on allait faire des troupes
d'assaut
l'ong qui est extrêmement importante
aussi c'est là où la guerre s'est
terminée pour le canada avance bien et
c'était aussi le point d'entrée des alba
sur le territoire belge alors c'était
symbolique aussi ce que les élites et
les britanniques sur ce front là sur le
front de la somme avait perdu six cent
mille hommes
alors les canadiens ont finalement
réussi à capturer le terrain qui était
très symbolique puis le match donc c'est
en belgique que se termine la guerre
commence là où ce dernier soldat
canadien george price l'a fait la guerre
l'armée canadienne est considéré par le
haut commandement britannique et
français comme probablement la larme il
a plu des troupes d'assaut la troupe des
sceaux c'est là c'est l'armée qui a
vraiment qui a vraiment su s'adapter aux
conditions imposées par l'arc par
l'artillerie mitrailleuses ils ont
développé une méthode de faire la guerre
john key qui est devenu une référence
ça c'est le cimetière militaire de mons
où à côté de mons 1 je crois où sont
enterrés des soldats mais aussi des
soldats allemands et des soldats
canadiens
donc voilà savez c'est cette vision
aussi d'inspecter le cimetière canadien
on le disait à 2 minutes à 2 minutes
avant d'entrer en vigueur
c'était maps sur wii tellement absurde
alors si c'est là qu'était notre
gouverneur général hier justement pour
ces cérémonies en l'honneur de georges
pion par an par deux lavabos la
contribution canadien c'est vrai que les
canadiens ont subi ont été victimes la
première attaque d'un programme combat
qu'il peut et libre en avril 1915 sont
aussi on doit se souvenir
ça vous parlais tantôt de l'abu dhabi
pour vous avez évoqué la brutalisation
de la première guerre mondiale
la violence de la rosa les gaz de combat
son plus bel exemple il n'ya plus bien
sûr de survivants de cette première
guerre mondiale
ici mais quand même on le voit le
souvenir de cette guerre dont il entend
nos deux qu'il ne faut pas oublier parce
que quand même le temps passe mais c'est
important de se rappeler parce que là on
voit ce sommet de l'apec est organisé
par par emmanuel macron à paris et les
thèmes qui reviennent on en a entendu
monsieur macron a dit attention le
nationalisme est une trahison
madame merkel a dit il faut faire
attention elle part de son inquiétude
est de nouveau face à nationalisme
arrière qu'on recommence à agir comme si
on pouvait purement et simplement ignoré
nos engagements réciproques alors
l'importance de la coopération
internationale
coco l'on souligne aujourd'hui alors que
justement il ya une montée du populisme
du repli sur soi il ya des craintes
quand même que les craindre
injustifiable parce qu'en fait puis ce
qui s'est passé les jeux tous les
mécanismes internationaux concernés
justement pour s'assurer pas voir
d'autres conflits présentement sont
réellement remise en question par
beaucoup de pays parce qu'elle impose
également des lignes directrices mais
ils ont peu de moyens pour s'assurer que
les pays se conforme avec ces choses là
alors c'est pour ça notamment que le
président des états unis est un peu
soucieux la conception canadien sur la
contribution américaine à l'otan alors
que il était le plus gros bailleur de
fonds des états unis ont toujours été le
plus gros bailleur de fonds de l'onu
n'ont pas ça et ils ont jamais réussi à
avoir finalement la reconnaissance pour
ça faut dire que les américaines durant
la première guerre mondiale sont arrivés
très tard en 1917
mais ils ont réellement précipité à ce
moment là la fin de la guerre parce que
là il était rendu impossible selon
l'état major allemand d'un gagné la
guerre et ils ont été approchés
comment leur autorité civile pour
commencer à négocier d'armistice et
c'était c'était quand même assez
mouvants de voir hier je sais pas si on
pourrait voir ces images mais des
manuels macron et de angela merkel qui
est se sont retrouvés dans une
reproduction du wagon c'est signé alors
voilà le fameux wagon du maréchal chef
alors les voies la côte à côte
symbole très fort quand même de cette
réconciliation franco-allemande dont on
a parlé
d'autant plus qu'en 1940 1940 hitler
avait exigé la reddition française dans
le wagon de retenter où les allemands
avaient capitulé en mineur avait
similaire me 6,1 deux ans plus tôt et
l'important c'est le message si jamais
on veut que ça se répète il faut
véritablement qu'il soit prendre en
compte justement qu'on peut pas ou une
attitude revancharde si jamais ianu de
conflit mais plutôt avoir une attitude
de reconstruction et de réconciliation
ce qui manquait à la fin de la première
guerre mondiale alors voilà ces images
au monument commémoratif de guerre à
ottawa
dans quelques instants il y aura la
traditionnelle bénédiction et ensuite le
défilé des anciens combattants qui va se
mettre en branle avec les jeunes des
moins jeunes des noës anciens
combattants on a vu quelques autochtones
en fille en fait parmi la foule ddv
terrain c'est un fait souligné ils ont
une présence proportionnellement très
importante durant la première guerre
mondiale
l'essai se poursuit mais une acceptation
beaucoup plus grandes aussi maintenant
de leurs traditions à travers toutes les
cérémonies cancan dans des cérémonies
mais il a évidemment et puis l'autre
chose aussi au tout début de ce disque
en avait beaucoup c'était convient de
deux sondes à 11500 amérindiens d'arges
militaires se sont enrôlées entre 1914
1918 paris au départ ils n'étaient pas
les bienvenus on n'en voulait pas
finalement les accepter que passant de
c'est quand même un tiers des
amérindiens en âge de combattre les
jours on va écouter un petit peu la
cérémonie on vous retrouve tout de suite
après
[Musique]
nous sommes d'ici ce cet emplacement
sacré prône souvenir était modérée
regardez voici rassemblés en ce lieu
sacré sanctifié par le souvenir est
sentie fia jamais par le sang précieux
verser ici même nous sommes ici pour
nous souvenir pour exprimer avec force
notre gratitude à nos anciens
combattants surveiller vos yeux vous
unir à moi pour exprimer notre gratitude
à nos anciens combattants ce en disant
nous vous sommes reconnaissants
quand vous entendrez les moore c'est
pourquoi nous nous souvenons c'est
pourquoi nous vous sommes reconnaissants
nous rappelons le sacrifice suprême que
tant de chair canadiens ont fait et on
était prêt à faire sur terre dans l'air
et en mer les morts les blessés les
survivants les endeuillés des hommes et
des femmes des anglophones des
francophones des membres des premières
nations
les gens de diverses communautés
ethniques et religieuses c'est pourquoi
nous vous sommes reconnaissants nous
nous rappelons qu'ils ont mis leur vie
en suspens qui l'ont mise en danger pour
éliminer la tyrannie et défendre la
liberté
les jeunes anciens combattants et des
anciens combattants plus âgés qui se
rassemblent aujourd'hui dans le respect
l'admiration mutuelle partenaires dans
la bataille contre le mal c'est pourquoi
nous vous sommes reconnaissants ils nous
rappelons qu'ils ont livré notre combat
pour garantir notre liberté notre
immunité à toutes et à tous ces héros
authentique mérite d'être célébré
applaudi et remercier éternellement
c'est pourquoi nous vous sommes
reconnaissants
nous rappelons leur courage leur dignité
leur générosité leur amour du canada
leur dévouement à la cause de la liberté
de la paix dans le monde
leur façon d'incarner nos valeurs dans
des situations difficiles
c'est pourquoi il vous sommes
reconnaissants nous rappelons qu'ils
savent que si jamais ils reviennent
indemnes physiquement ils seront
toujours exposé à des mots comme le
stress post traumatique et qui
continueront de mettre en jeu leur
avenir pour nous c'est pourquoi nous
vous sommes reconnaissants nous nous
rappelons ce qui a inspiré leur
générosité leur dévouement qui nous
renvoie ce que cela veut dire que d'être
canadiennes et canadiens
c'est pourquoi nous vous sommes
reconnaissants
avec tendresse et celles qui sont
disparus que les blessés connaissent la
guérison du corps et de l'esprit est que
ceux et celles qui ont servi et continue
de servir vivent leur vie dans un monde
libéré de la terreur est empreint de
sérénité
le genre de montée se sont battus pour
susciter et préservé comment témoigner
de notre gratitude à nos anciens
combattants qui sont les premiers
répondants une image en les accueillant
en les étreignant en remerciant tous
ceux que nous rencontrons partout et en
tout temps patine enseignants à nos
enfants
tout ce que nous ne cesserons de leurs
deux voix en ce 100e anniversaire de la
fin de la première guerre mondiale
nous réfléchissons à l'idée de guerre
mondiale nous nous demandons
puisque le monde peut être en guerre
s'il ne serait pas possible que le monde
soit en paix ce n'est pas seulement
possible c'est terriblement nécessaire
mais pas une paix qui nous soit caps ans
de guerre nous voici rassemblés ici
aujourd'hui en quête de monde qui soit
vraiment en paix une paix sous le signe
du respect de l'inclusion de la
coopération de l'entrée de la bonté et
d'une immense gratitude
tel est le but ultime de notre souvenir
un monde d'harmonie si le but est élevé
notre engagement le poursuivre et sans
faille et notre espoir de l'atteindre
inébranlable nos anciens combattants
continuent de lutter pour un monde
meilleur
poursuivons ce combat sonné tout faire
le mal par notre bienveillance en allant
à la rencontre les uns des autres dans
un esprit d'amitié en inondant le monde
de geste de bonté continueront à faire
en sorte que le canada soit digne de
leur dévouement
puissent leurs souvenirs et notre
gratitude couronné de gloire nous
anciens combattants et notre pays
que dieu bénisse nos anciens combattants
que dieu bénisse centraux que dieu
bénisse tous ceux et celles qui veillent
sur nous et défendent la paix ici et à
l'étranger
que dieu bénisse le canada amen
alors voilà cette bénédiction du rabbin
burqa pendant qu'on voit ces acteurs
donc avec les uniformes de l'époque de
la première guerre mondiale en cuir
comme vous disiez pas très fin très
choquant plus quand on sait à quel point
tu es de gortex n'existait pas à
l'époque c'était très haut dit mme en
terre en fête et puis c'est être d une
forme de laine bien aussi pratiquement
terminées maintenant on voit la
gouverneure générale elle est saluée des
anciens combattants qui sont sur place
et on se prépare maintenant pour ce
fameux du filet moment je faisais qui
est toujours important pour eux parce
que c'est quand même une reconnaissance
une fois par année où on peut avoir
témoigné de la gratitude et ça nous
permet aussi de voir que le visage de
ses anciens combattants et là beaucoup
changé alors pendant qu'on voit la
gouverneure générale on pourrait
peut-être juste parler de dessus de ses
anciens combattants de leur nombre un
petit peu de la deuxième guerre mondiale
il en reste maintenant 41 1100 juste un
peu plus de 41 mais la moyenne d'âge est
de 93 ans donc en voilà quelques-uns
improbable mais bien millions de
canadiens qui s'était enrôlé 39 et 45 1
millions pour celui qui en reste de la
guerre de corée il y aurait 7200 leur
moyenne d'âge est de 86 ans
mais les plus nombreux sont des anciens
combattants des conflits les plus
récents on peut penser à la bosnie à
l'afghane à l'afghanistan
ils sont 6 en 1 mil et leur moyenne
d'âge est de 58 ans oui alors quand même
des gens dont la moyenne d'âge est de 58
ans ça veut dire que ces gens là vont
vivre assez longtemps comment comment
gouvernement peut les aider ça reste
toujours une question un peu délicate
c'est à des liqueurs et puis évidemment
ce qu'il faut noter ce que quand même il
y en a qui reviennent avec des blessures
physiques
c est des blessures mental aussi tout ça
c'est la reconnaissance de ces maladies
la tarde à venir et surtout tarder à
dépister les maladies et avoir un moyen
de contrôler leurs problèmes on est à
dire adéquatement fouet puis écoutez si
vous regardez le la liste de toutes les
tentatives ont été faites depuis 1905
1914 en fait khatera de découvrir le
fameux trauma de shellshock il ya eu
beaucoup d'hésitations n'a par des
psychiatres des de toutes les
communautés médicales
même à l'intérieur des communautés
médicales dans les années 10 essais dans
les années 20 on ne reconnaissait pas la
psychiatrie et il vous dira que dit la
loi l'on parle de loin effectivement
et puis encore aujourd'hui c'est est ce
qu'on peut réellement dépister ce monde
là ceux qui n'ont pas de problème
aujourd'hui qui sont venus une mission
ça ne veut pas dire nécessairement qu'il
ne va pas tomber
justement à développer parce que il ya
toujours des problèmatiques convient
convient c'est le syndrome survivent en
étant de savoir pourquoi - j'ai réussi à
passer au travers alors que la section
avec lesquels j'étais il y en a trois
qui sont mal alors au fur et à mesure qu
y en a qui vont comme étole l'acte
irréparable
une fois de retour au pays bas ça ça va
mettre tout le monde en question
justement
oui alors vous parlez vous parlez de ça
on a on a un autre un autre chiffre
peut-être qui est important a montré ce
qu'il y avait eu de 2004 à aujourd'hui
il ya eu 2 122 anciens combattants et
réservistes qui se sont enlevé la vie
oui parler de ce soldat donc l'office de
la mer mais quand on regarde ce chiffre
de 122 mais c'est évidemment une partie
aussi une partie la réalité seulement
sont pas si la réalité parce qu'on est
quand même en difficulté a retracé ceux
qui ont quitté les forces comme par
exemple on parlait du jeune jonas damas
kwenge il y en a certains qui lui a
commis l'acte irréparable alors qu'il
était encore un uniforme à petawawa mais
certains ont quitté les forces
immédiatement après la mission parce que
vous deux pour tourner dans d'autres
missions
alors ces gens là finalement les
détecter et puis retracer si oui ou non
on a une vision globale de tous les lits
suicide qui a fait que les gens des
forces armées train de la faire à cause
de ces décès ces conditions là parce que
on transfère le dossier aux anciens
combattants canada mais si la personne
ne reconnaît pas avoir des séquelles
à ce moment le chercheur au jet d'encre
pas partie des states
alors très difficile à votre assise
douceur d'avoir un portrait complet
est ce qu'il ya une chimie six anciens
combattants dan est de reconnaître
qu'ils ont des problèmes
il ya effectivement dans cette interview
il n'y a pas d'erreur c'est un tabou
sociétale par semaine tous les personnes
qui souffrent de dépression ou quoi que
ce soit on a toujours des
questionnements c'est est ce que c'est
un tire-au-flanc quelqu'un qui se
camoufle pourriez pas travailler alors
il ya toute cette interrogation l'acquis
mais finalement les problèmes
manteaux dans un espèce de flou qui ne
sert à personne là l'organisation
mais on peut imaginer que c'est très
difficile d'admettre se l'admettre de
soi même brillamment et puis s est une
scierie comme une pelure d'oignon la
première personne la première couche de
l'union c'est la personne doit
reconnaître qu'elle un problème la
famille doit l'aider ou aussi prendre
connaissance de sorts et puis par la
suite on élargit le cercle finalement
qui peut aider la personne mais a vendu
seulement une certaine ouverture
maintenant au moins de reconnaître que
le problème existe
la gouverneure générale qui a enregistré
un message sur cette journée du souvenir
où elle parle justement de ses blessures
non seulement des blessures physiques
mais des blessures de là où la mer par
exemple au lendemain de la première
guerre mondiale
on a reconnaissez pas des victimes de
traumatismes psychologiques de charles
schwab
on prétend d'excès de l'antique cité des
comportements féminins et des
enfantillages et qu'on dit que la
meilleure façon de les traiter c'est de
décider de leur refuser la pension
d'ancien combattant
c'est la perception en 1919
vous imaginez mais aussi j'ai des
services de ce qu'on peut faire pour les
aiguilles a quand même toujours des
problèmes aujourd'hui pendant que ce
défilé se met en branle vous le voyez
pas ce qu'à leur retour au pays
le combat pour beaucoup d'anciens
combattants de deux militaires en fait
n'est pas terminée doivent se battre
encore pour obtenir de différents
paliers de gouvernement des services de
l'aide certain montant d'argent aussi
saint thibault des choses qui sont
toujours pas réglés on va rejoindre
daniel thibault à ottawa parce que cette
semaine daniel on a repris qu'à 270
mille anciens combattants qui ont été
victimes d'une erreur une erreur
comptable mais une erreur quand même de
165 millions de dollars qu'ottawa doit
leur rembourser une tache sur une autre
tâche dans ce dossier là qui a ré que le
gouvernement réponde m'en a voulu éviter
en tout cas pas la semaine juste avant
le jour du souvenir c'est un besoin des
vétérans céline qui a découvert cette
erreur là imaginé pendant huit ans on a
omis de calculer un crédit d'impôt de
bases province
y aller quand est venu le temps de
calculer la valeur de la pension
d'invalidité de ses 270 mille deux cent
soixante douze mille anciens combattants
donc ce que ça veut dire c'est que
pendant huit ans ils ont reçu quelques
centaines quelques milliers de dollars
de moins
on a déterminé l'erreur on va la
corriger le gouvernement s'est engagé
mais ça va prendre du temps on parle
d'une solution qui sera appliqué sur
quelques mois voire même peut-être
quelques années et est ce qui est triste
dans tout ça c'est que des gens qui
profitait de pensionnat pour le corps
des vétérans de la seconde guerre
mondiale la guerre de corée et en à 175
milles qui sont décidés des décès des
pardons et puis début de l'erreur donc
ça veut dire que c'est la succession
ce sont les enfants ces gens là qui vont
qui vont qui vont recevoir une partie de
la somme mais c'est de l'argent dont six
oreilles dont il aurait eu bien besoin
brise mais ma bref une autre une autre
tâche à ce dossier là pour le
gouvernement
tu as eu de la difficulté le chrono
précédent monsieur trudeau aussi on la
difficulté à gérer toute la question des
pensions et des sommes versées aux
anciens combattants de façon adéquate à
soulève encore des questions ça soulève
encore de la contrebasse oui c'est on y
ait toujours des histoires qui
ressortent comme celles-là mêmes cette
question là vous dites ça va être réglé
par le gouvernement daniel mais ça va
prendre encore quelques années donc il
ya d'autant plus de personnes qui ne
seront plus là pour pouvoir profiter et
récupérer cet argent là voilà et est en
attente et y avait de la pression qui
est émis cette semaine tant par les
partis d'opposition par les groupes par
les groupes représentant les anciens
combattants pour tenter de faire
accélérer les choses mais compte tenu de
la profondeur de la gravité de l'erreur
ça risque de prendre
petit bout de temps pour pouvoir régler
voilà la gouverneure générale qu'on
après soit à qu'on l'aperçoit qui donc
saluer ses anciens combattants qui passe
et qui défilent devant elle alors toutes
sortes de deux régiments toutes sortes
de danses un combattant qui viennent de
tout de toutes les parties de la remise
de tous les goûts tous les trois sur v
c'est à dire la barre et de navigation
et l arme était évidemment de vous pour
venir cependant au problème des anciens
combattants si c'est pas d'hier que ce
problème existe en fait tout de suite
avec la fin de la première guerre
mondiale
on a constaté que le gouvernement
n'était pas tellement réellement chaud à
l'idée de récompenser ou de compenser
finalement pour tous ceux qui ont
souffert de la guerre qui on venait soit
avec un arbre à - ou bien conscients
puisqu'ils après que c'est important et
il ya eu à ce moment là beaucoup
d'organisations civiles qui ont comparé
les relais modestement je dois le dire
la légion canadienne en état et puis
même pour intérêts des militaires
n'avait pas assez d'argent pour l'europe
sépulture
il ya eu le front de souvenirs qui
s'occupe de cela alors il sait existe
facile en fait un hommage aux anciens
combattants qui reviennent oui et même
aujourd'hui vous savez il ya des anciens
combattants on parle toujours comme de
quoi vous allez on a une armée de
carrière qui a des pleins qui qui est du
soutien qu'ils des fonds de retraite etc
mais la moyenne de durée d'un service
militaire d'un canadien de moins de 12
ans alors la personne n'aurait pas de
pension à ce moment là on va avoir en
retour de ces contributions aussi tout
et puis encore une fois il ya des jeunes
qui arrivent requis
fonds vont compléter simplement leur
engagement initial ont fait 3 5 1 vont
peut-être faire pendant une opération de
revenir mais des problèmes et n'auront
pas de pension alors comment détecter
ces personnes là comment les autres
acides cette errance et c'est toute une
problématique
on va aller rejoindre maintenant camille
simard la croix du sacrifice à québec où
l'on en a aussi souligné aulas aussi
souligner le jour du souvenir et je vois
derrière vous que c'est tout blanc la
came il ya eu la neige à québec moyenne
centaines de personnes qui ont bravé le
froid pour cette cérémonie qui souligne
aller sans temps de l'armistice céline
on va vous montrer parce que vous
reconnaissez sans doute la croix du
sacrifice donc la cérémonie ci qui va se
terminer
il ya plusieurs dignitaires qui sont
présents notamment le premier ministre
du québec françois legault jean yves
duclos le ministre de la famille fédéral
donc les deux qui ont déposé une gerbe
de fleurs donc à 300 militaires de
différents corps qui sont réunis ici à
québec et c'est spécial cette année la
cérémonie qui est un peu plus longue
qu'à l'habitude parce que on veut
souligner les exploits du corps
expéditionnaire canadien en france
pendant la première guerre mondiale
donc pendant cette cérémonie c'est les
noms on a entendu plusieurs coups de
canon alors une très belle cérémonie qui
est sur le point de se terminer
donc les militaires qui vont parader ici
et qui vont se rendre tout juste à côté
au manège militaire
j'ai parlé pour ma part un vétéran qui
compte plus de 20 ans d'expérience dans
l'armée qui est allé notamment en bosnie
vous en parliez tout à l'heure il a tenu
à souligner cette journée l'importance
justement qu'ont eue les militaires par
le passé on va écouter monsieur gosselin
pour le centième c'est spécial parce que
c'est la signature de l'armistice comme
nous diviser puis il faut passer aux
gens qui sont partis d'ici pour aller
combattre en europe puis vraiment c'est
c'est sûr qu'au québec au sujet du match
est un peu différent mais il faut
vraiment que les gens pensent assauts
pendant le petit deux semaines par
annick sadoul la campagne du feq likoud
il faudrait qu'il ya une plus grande
sensibilisation
oui alors cet ancien combattant très
justement dit qu'il faut que les gens se
souviennent il faut qu' il faut que les
gens soient sensibilisés un peu oui
voilà et je termine un céline en vous
parlant justement du manège militaire
qui va ouvrir ses portes c'est pas banal
à compter de midi jusqu'à 15h justement
pour que les citoyens de québec
même les touristes plus en apprendre
plus sur l'histoire militaire donc le
manège militaire qui va ouvrir ses
portes également pour souligner cette
journée spéciale
très bien merci et camille et les
commémorations ont aussi eu lieu à
montréal des centaines de personnes ont
d'abord assisté à une messe ce matin à
la cathédrale marie reine du monde
une cérémonie commémorative s'est
ensuite tenue à la place du canada en
présence du lieutenant gouverneur du
québec michel doyon de la mairesse de
montréal valérie plantes et de la
ministre n'est là ni joly arrivée de
lagarde a aussi pris haïti était
précédée de 21 coups de canon qui ont
retenti et pour clore les commémorations
et définissent mettra bientôt en marche
là aussi dans les rues du centre-ville
alors on parle beaucoup de ses anciens
combattants mais il ya quand même des
soldats qui des militaires canadiens qui
sont déployés en ce moment ils y ont
pourrait peut-être voir quelques
chiffres parce que il y en a quand même
un certain nombre il ya des opérations
qui sont plus évidemment qu'ils sont un
peu plus
l'entente là je pense qu'on voit le
tableau sur les suicides mais sur les
opérations en cours
il y à des soldats qui sont déployés en
voix voilà en irak lui à 130 en lettonie
opération réassurance 835 unifie en
ukraine 200 soldats et surtout celle
dont on parle beaucoup cette opération
militaire là au mali 250 soldats
ça c'est une ça faisait longtemps en
fait que le canada s'était pas retrouvée
dans une mission sous l'égide de l'onu
s'est quand même revenir
andrea notre miss peut-être enfin une
certaine tradition canadienne ou parce
que les casques bleus est midi
canadienne ni casque plus une idée de
lester b pearson issue de la guerre de
entre israël il ay l'egypte en 1956 avec
une intervention franco britannique et
les spéculations qui était ministre des
affaires étrangères à ce moment là dans
le gouvernement de louis saint laurent
avait eu l'idée de créer cette espèce
cette force d'interposition pour séparer
les égyptiens et israéliens et sept
cette idée avait fait école et le canada
6 s'est distingué pendant les décennies
en participant aux missions paix s'est
interrompu au cours des années 2000
en fait on n'a pas toutes les missions
paix à partir de la création justement
de l'unef nouvelle à la force
d'intervention
au moyen-orient et puis
dernièrement je pense qu'on a quand même
connu une éclipse as importante depuis
la fin des années 90 était remplacé
plutôt pour des missions dans le cadre
de l'otan mais il faut souligner quand
même que l'onu reconnaît le fait que
quand c'est ce sont des missions qui
risque d'être musclé bain et qui risque
jusqu'à six années alors qu on voit la
liste dans ces véhicules sont des
véhicules courrensan et ca va chercher
oui bah en fait depuis napoléon le
drapeau qui représentait au nord de
bataille de la tyrie ce sont leurs
cadeaux alors vous avez vu des drapeaux
qui ont défilé avec les vétérans et puis
là c'est le tour de la série de défilés
avec ses de la peau qui sont leurs
canons et donc on parlait de cette
mission au mali c'est quand même une
mission qui est assez risqué
c'est là où il ya eu le plus de morts et
pas dans la mission comme tels parce que
la mission est ciblé il faut pas se fout
pas se le cacher cependant le rôle
canadien est un peu quand même plus un
peu moins dangereux puisqu'il consiste
surtout à procéder aux évacuations
médicales
alors ils ont deux hélicoptères qui
normalement accompagne cette espèce de
quelles mains de salles d'opération
volante qui le chinook est à ce moment
là où j'avais su peu plus de sécurité
mais encore une fois ce qu'on a appris
de l'afghanistan c'est que peu importe
la tactique que vous employez le façon
neutraliser la menace ils vont toujours
s'adapter vivons toujours trouvé un
nouveau moyen ils n'ont pas besoin
d'aller au conseil du trésor pour avoir
une folie qui m'a mais est en principe
les soldats canadiens ne sont pas en
contact direct avec la supposée nom y
soit ou pas ils sont assis sur des
sentiers à protéger son engin dans un
terrain d'aviation qui protégeait et qui
ont leurs propres éléments de de
protection à l'intérieur ou temps
lorsqu'ils sont en garnison que lorsqu
ils se dépouillent bas dès qu'ils
atterrissent ya quelqu'un qui se déploie
pour assurer une sécurité périphérique
de l'endroit où ils vont procéder à
l'évacuation médicale
on va retourner à ottawa où vous voyez
sur ces images là la cérémonie se
termine la gouverneure générale et son
fils quitte en ce moment le monument
commémoratif de guerre et on va les
retrouver daniel parce qu'il ya le
centre national des arts quai situé
juste en face du ce site des
commémorations qui a tenu à souligner à
sa façon le 100e anniversaire de cette
fin de la première guerre mondiale avec
une programmation spéciale daniel oui
j'en ai discuté la semaine dernière avec
alexander scheer hisser leur chef
d'orchestre de la caisse un physique du
centre national des arts organisé entre
autres deux éléments majeurs vendredi
avait le warwick willem de benjamin
britten que l'orchestré du cn a
interprété avec l'orchestré national des
jeunes d'allemagne et cet après midi à
12h30
on ouvre les portes juste à côté si le
centre national des arts ce concert
gratuit c'est la présentation la
première mondiale du monde se souvient
qui a été écrit justement pour souligner
le 100e anniversaire de l'armistice je
me suis entretenu avec le maestro et
deux musiciens qui participent à la
performance d'aujourd'hui pour parler de
l'importance de ce devoir de mémoire
voici ce que ça donne music is
[Musique]
tickxpress le monde se souvient est un
cycle et de chansons écrites pour
commémorer le centenaire de la première
guerre mondiale
c'est un hommage à la génération touchée
par la grandeur la musique campagne les
paroles de poètes de guerre de mères de
soldats et des civils originaires des
pays de la première guerre mondiale
ce concert serait avec l'orchestré
national des jeunes du canada aucc
extraits et des choeurs combiné de la
région
on attendait
vous avez 18 ans durant la première
guerre vous auriez pas été
automatiquement construire mais vous
auriez pu y participer d'une façon ou
d'une autre
qu'est ce que ça change la perspective
dans votre tête quand vous êtes sur
scène et que vous offrir ce genre de
concerne tout à fait en jouant
il faut faire attention qu'on pleure pas
presque parfois parce que c'est la
musique elle est très mouvante et on
pense aux monuments on pense à tout ce
qui s'est passé
ça fait quand même quelque chose au
coeur on penche sur les guerres on
essaie de comprendre les seuils de 8 2 m
dans ce moment là qu'on n'a pas pu qu'on
n'a pas vécu en fait et c'est très
émouvant
je réfléchissais hier par la cour joue
et que je me disais les flots sur la
scène de présentement il y aurait été
construit il serait à la guerre serait
pas mal ici
[Musique]
en tout
quand même on termine ou enfin notre
émission s'achève sur une note d'espoir
quand même de ce chef d'orchestre qui
parle quand même des avancées qui a eu
ils devront revoir devoir maintenant les
pays côte-à-côte l'allemagne la france
il ya quand même quelque chose là-dedans
qu'est-ce qu'il faut selon vous qu'on
retienne dit cérémonie d'aujourd'hui
andré le plus évident il devoir de
mémoire mais moi à ce titre je veux dire
une chose qui m'a paraît extrêmement
important on a toujours reproché aux
canadiens français de ne pas avoir pour
avoir accompli leur devoir 14,8
ce que les historiens ont récemment
démontré c'est que près de 70 mille
canadiens françaises sont enroulés et
l'unité la plus canadienne de toute
l'armée canadienne a du répondant et
lausanne
c'est le 22e régiment qui était à 90 %
canadien
donc quelque part nous l'avons fait
notre droit et j'estime qu'on doit le
rappeler c'est pas uniquement la crise
la conscription s'est pas uniquement les
fusillades de québec en avril 1918 14,8
ça doit vous faire du bien d'entendre ça
quand même
bah oui brigadier-général vous qu'est ce
que vous pensez
oui qu'est ce que vous pensez que les
gens doivent retenir
doivent comment ils doivent se souvenir
rapidement bah c'est sûr qu'il faut que
célèbrent le sacrifice des soldats sont
aussi sur ta valaisan et août en sus de
la première guerre mondiale que
présentement succès en mission ce n'est
pas un éloge pour faire la guerre web là
parce que celui qui le vécu veut
certainement pas y retourner
alors voilà les gens ils déposent leur
cote l'ico puisque la cérémonie
maintenant terminée sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu donc ce rallye quand même
se rappeler puis aussi éviter les
erreurs du passé en étant plus
conciliant puis aussi en renforçant des
institutions internationales qui peuvent
aider justement désamorcer des
situations qui peuvent être exploitées à
dix paroles très sage merci beaucoup à
vous deux dames ont repris ce plateau
alors voilà c'est là dessus que se
termine cette émission spéciale du jour
du souvenir merci à vous tous d'avoir
été là le téléjournal du midi suis dans
un instant on va se laisser sur les
images des moments marquants de ces
cérémonies ici et ailleurs
au revoir
[Musique]